[Music]
look Slim Shady is back and got Beyonce
information for his comeback song
inspiring um that we have so much good
music what you just made me do
no poverty swift reputation Friday has
been interrupted
[Music]
why expectations so high is it the bar I
set my arms I stretch but I can't reach
eminem dropped his highly anticipated
first single walk on water
featuring Queen B on Friday the
emotional ballad takes a deep dive into
the expectations of Fame and living up
to his own reputation kids look to me as
a god this is [ __ ] if only they knew
it's a facade and it's exhaustive a
flawed human I guess but I'm doing my
best to not ruin your expectations and
meet them and B drives home the powerful
message even more in the hook
[Music]
just making my
so if you
this marks the first release since
Eminem returned to the spotlight in
October the rapper will perform his new
single for the first time on the MTV EMA
stage in London on November 12 no word
on whether Beyonce will join him but we
are thrilled to have Slim Shady back
[Music]
you